what is it that's a tie
if it wasn't just me who took it down
who was it another should be sir hi We
Need to Talk
who are you I'm your daughter Nora from
the future
anybody need a refill just me
people call me excess it's a nickname
you gave me when I was a kid and kind of
stuck here now
so anybody know what to do this is so
weird
god I love this place I can't believe
that's our daughter up there no I
shouldn't be here she could Marty McFly
herself out of existence she needs to be
with her parents
30 years from now not us no no what I
need to know my poker face is that bad
oh please why don't you keep this from
us I think I made a big big mistake
I'm sorry and we can't let this get any
worse here we go now let's do this
I don't have a suit actually I have a
backup total fan favorite
you have to look around corners see into
the shadows timings of gadgets lots of
deep in vigilantes are nuts you are just
afraid of the competition but it changed
[Music]
I thought masks were only big in that
other city you're gonna tell me who you
are
everybody we got new flash season 5
footage to break down we finally got the
flash ring I actually have a backup fan
favorite
she gives Barry the flash ring they're
finally doing the comic book flash ring
you probably recognized a couple really
big scenes right out of the comics too
in the first couple of episodes and some
of these scenes are actually deleted
scenes from the season 4 finale so I'll
explain which is which but we also got
that Batwoman teaser at the end - they
are really pushing that early they
haven't even cast that character yet and
they want you to remember we're doing a
big crossover and Batwoman is gonna be
introduced during it so if you're brand
new to the channel there's a new round
of that flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so they do
a quick recap of the final episode and
all the different times that Nora jumped
to see the team during the season they
don't come right out and say what Nora's
mistake was but the producers confirm
that it was a bunch of mistakes that
Nora made not any one single mistake and
the big mistakes would continue to
happen through the course of the season
as they try to solve this big problem
with cicada who is the confirmed villain
at the end there but the big scene at
the end where he walks in sits down at
the table and puts the lightning-shaped
Acker down right out of the comics
that's actually a deleted scene from the
season 4 finale there were reports about
a lightning-shaped dagger showing up but
they said that they cut that out just
because they didn't have enough time so
I'm guessing that they just tacked that
footage on to whatever the first episode
is going to be it's probably like the
post-credits scene from episode 1 grant
gustin's said that he felt like this
first episode season 5 episode 1 is
their best first episode of a season
since the pilot so I think they just
have the right material in the right
characters in the right setup to have
the best season of the flash so far it's
one of the same things that happen with
era where they had a really bad season
for but a really awesome season 5
because of prometheus so apparently the
trend in the arrowverse continues but
there's a couple of cool lines of
dialogue that they include in this Nora
shouldn't be here more of Barry's
gibberish that they didn't repeat or
maybe they cut it out of the finale like
maybe that dialogue is all from season 4
and it just got deleted because it
wasn't enough time big-name dropped for
Marty McFly I've been making all kinds
of Back to the Future jokes because
that's kind of how I've been thinking of
Nora's character she's the Marty McFly
but while they're mentioning that she
picks up the fan
picture just like the Back to the Future
photo she could Marty McFly herself out
of existence that's probably what the
big stakes are for them like Barry
probably falls in love with her like any
dad would fall in love with his daughter
over the course of the season he doesn't
know her that well right now but they'll
probably grow very close by the end of
the season and she'll almost be erased
and like that'll be the thing Barry has
to save his daughter or help her save
herself
they said that Nora's character is very
clingy with Barry but you don't know why
but if you've been watching the show
really carefully or you know the comics
really well you know exactly why she's
so clingy because Barry is dead in the
future where she comes from because of
crisis that's what that future newspaper
during the pilot episode is all about
flash vanishes in crisis but she's
actually very cold with Iris that's like
a completely separate storyline that
they'll explain and they finally
confirmed that Nora is excess she was
wearing a very excess looking costume so
it makes sense that she's that character
but they don't say anything about how
she's tied to the Legion of super-heroes
because that's who the excess character
belongs to in the comics so if she were
to become part of the Legion she would
also have to travel way into the future
and I'm not sure that they would do that
but Candice Patton said that iris is
really happy to get to know her but Nora
is still very cold with iris probably
because of this post-apocalyptic
wasteland that winds up happening
because of the cicada character the
villain can take away people's powers
but in the context of the TV show he
won't have a cold it'll be a little
different from the comics he just blames
metahumans for all of his problems he
probably had a family that died because
of them but he's immortal
so you get the idea he's not that
powerful right now but he gains more
power as he goes along so by the time
you get to Nora's time in 30 plus years
things are really really bad but
probably one of the biggest action set
pieces from I'm guessing the first
episode is Wally and Barry saving the
plane from crashing that's right out of
the comics the basic idea is is that
there's a plane crashing they phase all
of the passengers out before it crashes
the big thing about the crossover this
year too that they confirm is that it
would be episode 9 episode 9 of the
flash is the hundredth episode so on top
of all the Batwoman stuff that's
happening expect the flash part of the
crossover to be very special
or the flash characters a lot of
comic-book Easter eggs we might get to
see a vision of the future or the flash
Museum or something really cool they
confirmed that they're introducing
younger versions of the Rogues and in
the second half of the season king shark
in gorilla grodd are gonna team up so
like just really big stuff that they've
already planned ahead of time
speaking of which they confirmed that
berry would be getting a new flash
costume that's more comic-book accurate
to go with the flash ring but everybody
let me know what you think about the
Back to the Future season of the flash
that they're teasing I just think it's
gonna be really awesome they have a
chance to be the best season so far
there are a bunch of other DC TV
trailers I'll try to do a video for that
tomorrow but there's just so much stuff
dropping because of Comic Con leave all
your requests in the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner jade and derby please email me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details I'll name a new
winner when I post a new DC video click
here to rewatch the Shazam trailer a
billion more times and click here to
rewatch the Aquaman trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]